senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
agrees to a temporary debt ceiling
increase president biden's approval
rating plummets to shocking lows and
espn suspends sage steele for saying the
unsavable i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench bureau show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let bigtech track what you do
anonymize your web browsing at
expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first you are just paying too
much money to your cell phone provider
if you are using one of the big
providers like verizon or att or
t-mobile you're spending your money so
they can pay for their social
initiatives or their retail stores
across the country that you never
actually use instead what if you could
get the same exact service as one of the
big cell phone providers except you
would actually be spending a lot less
money this is where pure talk comes in
pure talk isn't going to charge you for
any of that crappy overhead instead they
give you killer 5g coverage on the same
5g network as one of the big guys for
about half the cost the average family
is saving over 800 a year so what is
your excuse i made the switch you can
keep your number keep your phone or get
huge discounts on the latest iphones and
androids get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data for just 30 bucks a month
and listen if you still want unlimited
data you can still get it and save a
fortune go to puretalk.com shop for the
plan that's right for you they have a
30-day risk-free guarantee so you
literally have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com enter promo code shapiro
you'll save 50 off your very first month
that is puretalk.com promo code shapiro
puretalk is simply smarter wireless
again puretalk.com promo code shapiro to
get started 30 day risk free guarantee
you got nothing to lose peertalk.com
promo code shapiro alrighty so
late last night mitch mcconnell the
senate minority leader he essentially
quote unquote caved to the democrats
what he did is he agreed to a short-term
debt ceiling increase the way this is
being characterized by the democrats is
a win for the democrats because instead
of them having to cram everything in in
the next couple of weeks and then ram
through a debt ceiling increase via the
use of reconciliation now they will
probably have more time to negotiate
negotiate out this build back better
regime this this terrifyingly large
package that they are putting together
so a lot of people on the right this
morning are very angry with mitch
mcconnell
i think in part justifiably so but i
think that there is a logic to what
mcconnell is doing and i think it has to
do mainly with joe manchin it certainly
does not have to do with biden so one of
the theories that is being trotted out
there is that mitch mcconnell caved
because joe biden's agenda is actually
popular and he didn't want to be seen
holding it up that of course is
absolutely nonsense that's very silly
joe biden
is really really unpopular the poll
numbers for joe biden are just awful
they are garbage quinnipiac which is a
polling service that tends to favor
democrats currently has joe biden's
approval rating at 38
remember that time we were told that
donald trump was historically unpopular
well
here you have joe biden who is basically
at the same level as trump was when
trump was at his lowest levels of
approval rating okay so these are really
bad numbers for biden and unlike donald
trump who had a pretty solid ceiling and
a pretty solid floor biden didn't really
have a ceiling but he also has an or no
floor what that means is that when he
starts to lose support there is no load
to which he cannot crater
maybe in the 20s somewhere but trump was
never going to crater below about 35
biden theoretically if things continue
to get bad he could be down in the low
30s before you know it on the issues the
only issue where biden is performing
even half decently is on covet even
there he's slightly underwater at 48.50
on the economy he has 39 approval rating
on being commander-in-chief he has 37
percent approval rating on taxes 37
approval rating on immigration 25
approval rating on the border 23
approval rating only 44 of americans say
that he is honest only 41 of americans
say that he is a leader and only 42 say
that he's competent
that is just brutal i mean those are
viciously brutal numbers for joe biden
and that means that he really has no
coattails and one of the reasons that he
has no coattails is of course because
joe biden is not with us
right there is no
there is no world in which people think
that he is capable of grabbing the bull
by the horns anymore because he is much
more likely to grab the bull and the
bull is likely to buck him and he is
likely to fall down and break a hip
this is why we are consistently on a
day-to-day level seeing the white house
attempting to guard joe biden the way
you would a nursing home patient from a
from a symptomatic five-year-old and so
joe biden yesterday
he was doing a live stream and his staff
just started ushering reporters out we
see this almost every week where people
are asking questions to joe biden all
the time they're getting shoved out of
the room they're using one of those old
vaudeville canes and they're grabbing
people and they're just yanking them out
here's what that sounded like
so thank you mr president for the
opportunity to speak to the impact of
not raising the debt bye guys
see you later in particular and then
nearly 65 million people across this
country so you're having the business
round table and you can see the
reporters just getting yanked out of
there wouldn't want anybody to ask any
inconvenient questions they also built
this very bizarre set for joe biden so
he's no longer speaking i guess from the
from the oval office instead they built
a socially distanced set for him which
just looks as though he's playing it
being president he's like underground in
a bunker somewhere with a digital
background that's projected to make it
look like he's in the oval office but he
isn't actually in the oval office it's
very very weird kind of stuff
terry mcauliffe is running a very
competitive race right now in virginia
mcauliffe theoretically should be
running away with that race right now
he's running basically dead even with
glenn youngkin in virginia that race is
slated to come to its terminus at the
beginning of november if jungkin wins is
going to shake things up radically for
the democratic party because again
mcauliffe was expected to be a shun he's
been governor of virginia before
virginia has been trending blue because
of all of the democrats who've been
moving to the virginia suburbs they can
work in washington dc
if mcauliffe were to lose that race that
would be a i mean red alarm defcon 1
kind of stuff for the democratic party
you're pushing too fast you're way too
radical you really need to moderate it
you need to hold it up
terry mcauliffe is openly now saying
that joe biden is a drag on his ticket
we got to get democrats out to vote
we are facing a lot of headwinds from
washington as you know the president
is unpopular today unfortunately here in
virginia so we have got to plow through
okay when you have
the guy who was the head of the dnc
terry mcauliffe saying that the
president is unpopular
in virginia which again is right outside
washington you see a lot of federal
employees in virginia that is a real
warning sign and so joe biden does not
have virtually any momentum at this
point and his agenda is way too radical
for the american people
this is the part that's truly
astonishing is that his origin again
i've said this a thousand times the only
reason that he was elected is because
one he was dead and two he was supposed
to be a dead moderate he has only kept
one of those promises he is not an alive
person but he is not moderate in any way
shape or form he had saki yesterday
proclaiming that she doesn't mind if
americans pay higher gas prices in order
to prevent climate change
how's that going to go over in middle
america jen
what cop 26 is about is to continue the
con the conversation
on the international stage at the leader
level that has been going on below the
leader level continuously basically
about our need to work together to
address the climate crisis uh one of the
greatest national security crises the
presidencies a number of other world
leaders agree on that front certainly we
all want to keep gasoline prices low uh
but uh the threat of the crisis uh the
climate crisis certainly can't wait any
longer
okay so
that sort of stuff is not going to go
well for the body administration so the
man has no coattails right he really
doesn't the one area where apparently
the democrats thought they could
consolidate is on the debt ceiling stuff
i'll get to that in just one moment
first let us talk about the simple fact
that you want to protect your home when
you are out of town when you're away
from your house you want to make sure
you know what's going on at your house
this is where ring alarm comes in so
when we moved from california to florida
my wife said let's put some ring devices
on the house like right away and the
good news is it was really easy to
install i could do it myself and i am no
tech wizard for sure with my ring alarm
security system i'm much more ease when
i'm on the road or away from home my
ring alarm equals peace of mind you can
protect your home with ring alarm too
ring alarm is a powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install yourself it works
seamlessly with other ring products in
one simple app for a special offer go to
ring.com it's the perfect way to start
your ring experience keep an eye on
every corner of your home with indoor
and outdoor cam see what's happening
directly from your phone protect your
home anytime from anywhere with ring
alarm and it's very useful to me like
i'm at work i want to check in on what
the kids are doing i just checked my
ring and i know exactly what is going on
somebody's dropping off a package i want
to make sure i know who it is ring comes
in handy go to ring.com for a special
offer on a ring alarm security kit today
you can build a system right for your
home have it up and running in just
minutes that is ring.com
again ring dot com slash ben okay so
joe biden is pushing an unpopular agenda
that is not likely to
win him many plaudits okay the build
back better agenda that he is pushing
right now is not in fact popular the
american people do not feel it is
necessary to blow out spending in taxes
at this point in time not when the
economy is teetering on the brink of a
serious slowdown thanks to both supply
bottlenecks and thanks to the fact that
the federal government has been paying
people to stay home the american people
are not on board with this and joe biden
has no traction on any of this he's now
been relegated to going back to the old
democratic standby if you by if of if
you disagree with me it's because you
want america to fail and so this was joe
biden speaking yesterday he went to
michigan an attempt to drum up support
for build back better
and his suggestion was that if you don't
agree with him then it's because you are
complicit in america's decline
to support these investments is to
create a rising america
america's moving
to oppose these investments is to be
complicit in america's decline
okay so in other words if you don't want
to spend five trillion dollars you want
america to decline first of all this is
rooted in such an economic fallacy it
makes your head spin if if joe biden's
idea is that the way that you build a
strong country a stronger economic
country that the way that you build a
stronger economy is to blow out the
spending on the taxes i would love to
see one country where this has been true
that blowing out spending in taxes is
what makes the economy hum
there there's
so little evidence of this it makes your
head swim and the fact is that in europe
when they blew out the spending during
the 1970s 1980s they got economic
stagnation they had to cut it this is
what's happened in places like sweden
and denmark and norway they actually had
to cut social services and they had to
scale back their tax and regulation
regime in order that their economy would
start growing again
even germany and france have had to do
this in the recent past
the the the united states is a great
example of this in the 1960s we had a
booming economy we were growing year on
year gdp was up like five percent six
percent a year and then thanks to fat
union contracts particularly in places
like the auto industry making those
industries less competitive combined
with lbj deciding that it was time to
blow out the spending we were going to
pay for both guns and butter the vietnam
war and massive social spending we saw
economic stagnation from essentially
1969 all the way until the early 80s
there is no evidence that these kinds of
quote unquote investments make the
economy run precisely the opposite when
you suck money out of the private sector
economy where risk
is either rewarded or punished
and instead you take that money and you
put it in a place where
where there is no question about risk
you can simply hand the money to your
favorite political constituencies and
bear no burden for having done so
see this is the thing about governmental
spending there's no feedback loop
if you spend money in a stupid way and
you are a government agent nothing
happens to you you retain your job if
you spend money in a stupid way
in the private sector you go under it's
always amazing to hear people jabber
about profit rate
and when you talk about the
profitability of companies on average
you're ignoring all the companies that
went under every time you decide to
start a company you are taking the risk
that the company goes under and that you
lose the money that you invested in the
company
when people talk about the average
profit
they're talking about the companies that
succeed that is a small subset of
companies period many many companies do
not succeed
but we have to incentivize innovation
and entrepreneurship and people taking
those risks that's what the market does
you reward successful risk takers and
you punish people who take bad risks
that is a feedback loop provided by all
other americans with regard to goods and
services when you invest when joe biden
talks about investment he's not talking
about natural investment strategy he
bears no risk for any of this
he can blow trillions of dollars on
random garbage and as long as that money
is going to people who are likely to
vote for him there's very little
blowback
the only way there's blowback if somehow
the american people realize that these
massive investments the size and scope
of these investments is actually
hampering the economy and that's
precisely by the way what these sorts of
investments do
the wall street journal has a good
editorial on this this morning they say
the lesson from europe's cradle to grave
welfare state
is that mr biden's expanded entitlement
is likely to be reduced incentive to
work and invest slower economic growth
lower living standards less fiscal space
for essential public goods like national
defense
most of the european cradle-to-grave
welfare states have older populations
than the united states says the wall
street journal this alone does not
account for their lower labor
participation rates and much higher
structural unemployment
european jobless rates tend to be much
higher than in the united states
especially for the young in 2019 labor
participation was 62.6 percent in the
united states versus 49.7 percent in
italy literally less than half of people
eligible to work in italy are working 55
percent in france 57 in spain 59 in
portugal 61 in germany
while the united states economy was slow
to recover from 2008 2009 because of
obama's policy uncertainty says the wall
street journal u.s gdp growth still
averaged 2.3 from 2010 to 2019
surpassing italy portugal spain france
and germany
democrats say that generous family leave
will encourage more women to work and
expand the workforce but italy offers 22
weeks of maternity leave at 80 of
previous earnings france provides 16
weeks at 90 spain 16 weeks at 100
why does that come along with higher
payroll taxes
what does that mean it means that people
have stopped hiring pregnant women or
women who are unlikely to be in the
workforce who are of child-bearing age
there are unfortunately economic
disincentives to hiring people who are
going to be out of the workforce for a
significant period of time that you then
have to pay for via payroll tax
europe's little disgust secret says the
wall street journal is that its cradle
to grave welfare states are financed by
the middle class via value added and
payroll taxes the combined employer
employee social security tax is 36 in
spain 40 in italy 65
in france value-added taxes in most
european economies are around 20
this isn't about paying this isn't about
the rich paying their fair share in
europe this is about everybody paying
through the nose
which is why the democrats are
attempting to gimmick the system
they're determined to gimmick the system
in fact a great example of a european
state that has realized this is sweden
right the the left likes to cite sweden
is a great example of this giant welfare
state sweden has been curbing
its benefits sweden has been scaling
back its taxes and regulation it's the
only reason that they started to grow
again because from 1970 to 1993 they
went from the fourth wealthiest economy
on planet earth it's like the 13th
wealthiest economy on planet earth and
then they started to realize we've done
some really stupid crap here
joe biden however seems to think that it
strengthens the economy to spend all of
this money
okay and this is not a it's not a
popular position which is why joe
manchin has been pushing back on it
right
and so joe manchin openly said yesterday
we should not be turning our society
into an entitlement society
i don't believe that we should turn our
society into an entitlement society i
think that we should still be a
compassionate rewarding society
i think that fairs best for all of us
but compassion means taking care of
those who can't take care of themselves
whether they're young whether they've
had some type of a of a
challenge in life whether it be mental
or physical those are responsibilities
that we have and we can all meet those
responsibilities
okay said his mansion pushing back on
the entire mentality that joe biden is
pushing and that has some pretty serious
consequences including a huge firefight
inside the democratic party right now
all this is predicates explaining what
mitch mcconnell is actually kind of
doing with the debt ceiling which again
is sort of i would say half justifiable
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the reality of
aging as you get older you tend to lose
family memories right they're all in the
garage the molds are you have tapes that
are falling apart you got old film reels
that stuff is just doing nothing out
there not only is he doing nothing it's
falling apart you're never going to see
it again why not just get all that stuff
digitized and preserved forever this is
what legacy box does i did this for my
parents it is it's just a godsend it's
wonderful we send them a box filled with
old video tapes and video reels and film
reels and they send you back a digitized
version of all of that stuff on a usb
drive or on a dvd and now it's preserved
for all time easy to access easy to give
to your family this week legacy box is
offering 40 off at legacybox.com shapiro
so you can start future proofing your
past today with legacy box you can
reclaim all that priceless footage you
haven't been able to see in years the
service could not be simpler use their
kit to safely send the moments you want
preserved their team will create a
digital archive by hand right here in
the united states then you'll receive
your new copies stored on the cloud
thumb driver dvd along with all the
original media you sent them
with their tracking system you can
follow every step of the process so you
always know your originals are being
taken care of once you have your digital
versions you can relax knowing they will
be secure for generations order in
minutes enjoy forever visit
legacybox.com take advantage of this
limited time offer for 40 off do it
right now use the kit whenever you're
ready that's legacybox.com shapiro say
40 right now legacybox.com
shapiro okay so what does this
materialize into this this sort of
firefight so joe manchin is now
demanding that progressives
quote-unquote prioritize their programs
he's telling his colleagues progressives
need to pick just one of biden's three
signature policies
and discard the other two according to
axios
by forcing progressives to choose among
an expanded child tax credit paid family
medical leave or subsidies for child
care manchin is complicating any
potential deal but also signaling his
willingness to negotiate says axios he's
also aligning himself with democratic
centrists in the house who want to trim
the number of programs in any final
package but fund them for longer meaning
mansion is not going along with the
budgetary gimmick that many of the
progressives have been urging which is
what if we fund all of the programs but
for like four years
right that is the gimmick instead of
making a 10-year bill we make it a
four-year bill spend the exact same
amount of money and then pretend that
we're not spending that much money
because we'll
artificially sunset the bills knowing
that congress is then going to come back
in and refund all of the bills like put
more money into the bills so manchester
no we're not going to do that if you
want to put together a program that
program is going to have to be budgeted
over the course of 10 years and that
means you're actually going to have to
pick and choose which programs you want
progressives are hopeful they can retain
all of their cherished programs in a
final bill by funding many of them for
shorter durations and lowering the
bill's ultimate price tag by essentially
lying to you mansion is saying no
mansion stress today his price cap
remains 1.5 trillion dollars
sanders the leading progressive
separately told reporters there are
quote 48 senators who support 3.5
trillion we have two people who don't so
sanders has been going nuts on all of
this he said it is wrong will you not
plan fair two people do not have a right
to sabotage what ford gate want again i
don't understand why bernie sanders
can't count i mean i do he's a socialist
that makes sense
right
numbers are very very hard for
socialists because socialism is rooted
in a complete unwillingness to look at
numbers so
you know when you have bernie sanders
saying
um 52 senators 52 senators senator
trumping 48 because when you add mansion
and cinema to the people who don't want
to vote for the bill that's 52 that's a
majority in the senate
the president has proposed extending the
expanded 3 600 per child tax credit
which he funded for one year in the
american rescue plan for another four
years that would cost 450 billion
dollars the cost for providing paid
family medical leave very wildly the
white house proposed 225 billion over 10
years in april but the house ways and
means committee is pricing it at 500
billion and whenever you start coming up
with these government estimates they're
always low by a factor probably a third
for biden's child and infant care
proposals which include subsidies for
poor and middle-class families for
daycare and two years of universal
preschool like head start which has been
a complete and utter federal failure the
house wants to spend 450 billion dollars
okay and uh mansion is saying no you are
going to have to cut a lot of this stuff
apparently mansion is pretty comfortable
with federal funding for universal
preschool but he views child and infant
care proposals as a separate program by
the way all the way back in the day
elizabeth warren you know the senator
she used to be a rather interesting law
professor at harvard law school she
wrote a book called the two income trap
in which she explicitly opposed
universal child and family care because
she said what this does is it
essentially creates a disincentive for
women to stay home and take care of
their kids if they want to do so it
forces family into what she called a
two-income trap driving up the price of
goods and services by requiring that
both parents work as opposed to one
staying home
this is when elizabeth warren was
actually a much more interesting human
being
okay so the biden versus mansion battle
is really a pitched one and not only
that
it's
pretty extraordinary to what level
people are angry at each other
how angry is bernie sanders at christian
cinema and joe manchin here's how angry
he is according to axios he actually
withheld support for a joint statement
condemning last weekend's protests
against senator kirsten cinema in
arizona because it also wouldn't include
a rebuke of her political views
so there's an attempt to put together a
joint statement from republicans and
democrats saying do not follow people
into bathrooms and harass them and
bernie was like nope i think it's okay
to follow people into bathrooms and
harass them
the only way that i will sign that
statement is if you also say the
question sentiment is a joke
if we'll say that she's a joke then i
will say it's bad to follow her into the
bathroom if you say she's not a jerk or
if you don't say anything then it's okay
to follow
it's unreal i mean this schmuck
you know
it was one of his supporters who
literally shot members of congress at a
baseball game not all that long ago
and now bernie's like i won't even
condemn people following a woman into a
bathroom it's fine i mean she has bad
views
according to axios the move is
emblematic of the hostility between the
progressive and moderate members who've
been sparring over the cost and scope of
president biden's agenda sanders wanted
the statement to urge cinema to draw
proposition to prescription drug reform
as well as biden's 3.5 trillion dollars
social safety net expansion
so again sanders communications director
mike casca he asked that the statement
be edited to include a preface quote
while we hope senator cinema will change
her position on prescription drug reform
and support a major budget
reconciliation bill
cory booker was like nope we're not
doing that
so sanders said i'm not gonna sign
please cut senate democratic leadership
team from the headline
pretty amazing stuff truly
i mean the email exchanges is pretty
insane the fact that that sanders team
was like well you know we're only going
to sign on to violence is bad so long as
we condemn the person against whom the
the
assault was done right that's
pretty wild stuff
but
this is one of the reasons why
basically mitch mcconnell's saying i
don't want to get in the middle of this
well let's
let them fight he's doing the godzilla
let them fight
that really is the strategy here so in a
second we'll get to all of the debt
ceiling related issues because there are
many
first let's talk about a simple fact if
you've got a small business you know
there's nothing more valuable than your
time so stop wasting it on trips to the
post office stamps.com makes it easy to
mail and ship directly from your
computer you can save time and money
with stamps.com send letters and
packages for less with discounted rates
from usps ups and more here at dailywire
we've been using stamps.com since 2017.
we don't waste our time since 1998
stamps.com has been an indispensable
tool for nearly 1 million businesses
stamps.com brings the services of the us
postal service and ups shipping directly
to your computer whether you're in
office sending invoices or a side hustle
etsy shop or a full-blown warehouse
shipping out orders stamps.com will make
your life easier all you need is a
computer and standard printer no special
supplies no equipment within minutes
you're up and running printing official
postage for any letter any package
anywhere you want to send it and you'll
get exclusive discounts on postage and
shipping from usps and ups once your
mail is ready just schedule a pick up or
drop it off no traffic no lines cut the
confusion out of shipping with
stamps.com's new rate advisor tool you
can even compare shipping rates and
timelines and find the best available
option
there's no risk with my promo code
shapiro you get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and digital scale no long term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on that microphone at
the top of the homepage type in shapiro
that is stamps.com promo code
shapirostamps.com never go to the post
office again
okay so
the debt ceiling debate right this
brings us all to the debt ceiling debate
and these two are intertwined so
basically the republicans had said to
the democrats we are not going to
bail you out of the debt ceiling problem
that you have you need to pass the debt
ceiling and you need to do it via
reconciliation the reason that
republicans wanted the democrats to do
it via reconciliation is twofold one
democrats can only use reconciliation
two times in a given year right that is
the bird rule they can only use
reconciliation two times in a given year
if they have to do it for just a debt
relief bill then this means that they
cannot use it three times right it means
that that becomes one of the issues on
which they've used reconciliation unless
they bundle it with their broader build
back better nonsense package or
bipartisan infrastructure package
right unless they partner with one of
those two and those things aren't
passing right now so this put democrats
in a bind they didn't want to use
reconciliation
and also they didn't want to use
reconciliation period for the debt
ceiling increase because when you do a
reconciliation bill for a debt ceiling
increase because of parliamentary
procedure basically for a wide variety
of reasons you get what is called a
vote-a-rama in which any amount of
amendments can be proposed to a debt
ceiling relief package and democrats
then have to vote up or down on all of
those things so republicans would
propose a lot of popular stuff democrats
would vote it down and then they'd all
be on record voting against that stuff
which is really bad for them
legislators always have an incentive not
to vote on specific issues but to vote
on giant broad
overarching packages because that way
they can say yeah you know i didn't like
this one provision but i did like the
overarching bill you know better to vote
for that crap sandwich then vote against
the crab sandwich what senators and
congress people fear more than anything
is single-issue bills where they are
forced to actually give their opinions
on single issues right they don't want
that because then they can be held
accountable for those opinions that's
what the voterama would have done so
the basic republican strategy here was
we are going to
tell you to do the debt ceiling yourself
okay then
the time on the debt ceiling grew rather
close
right
we were like two weeks away from the
debt ceiling
and the democrats started to panic
because the voterama would take longer
than a week right the voterama could
take a week ten days it's not it's
possible they wouldn't even get it done
and then they started to see that as
maybe an opportunity
maybe they could browbeat republicans so
if there was some sort of economic
fallout from the debt ceiling that if
they were playing chicken
maybe it would be better for biden to
simply let the car go over the cliff on
the debt ceiling and then blame
republicans this is sort of the going
theory we'll drag you down with us
and maybe they were able to convince joe
manchin right this is unclear whether
they were able to convince joe manchin
to kill the filibuster for the debt
ceiling increase
so manchin for his part said that he was
not going to do that but maybe the
reason that he said he was not going to
do that is because he'd already heard
from mcconnell that we were going to
push off the debt ceiling
here is joe manchin on this yesterday
i implore them
to engage start working work this out
there should not be a crisis
i've been very very clear where i stand
where i stand on the filibuster i don't
have to repeat that i think i've been
very clear
nothing changes
but for his part joe biden supposed
moderate was saying yesterday maybe
we'll change the filibuster rules in
order to pass the debt ceiling increase
are democrats considering using the
nuclear option to raise the debt limit
using a carve out with the filibuster to
raise the debt limit well i think that's
a real possibility
okay so they started talking about
killing the filibuster which would of
course have made the democratic 50 votes
plus kamala harris majority a lot more
credible in terms of the stuff that it
could do right the filibuster prevents
them from doing very very radical stuff
okay so this had been biden's pitch
biden's pitch was it's republican's
fault if we hit the debt ceiling now
again that's not true democrats can any
time they want pass the debt ceiling
through reconciliation
but this had become a major talking
point for the democrats they'd much
prefer to talk about the debt ceiling
than to talk about for example the
actual build back better plan because
the buildback better plan they're busy
battling that one out plus i have a
feeling that behind closed doors joe
manchin was basically saying listen
you've counted on me so far to hold the
line when it comes to the build back
better thing
but if we hit the debt ceiling there's
gonna be a lot of pressure on me to
basically strike back by helping to kill
the filibuster here because we can't let
the government go into complete shutdown
mode
right so i really think that probably
what happened here is that mcconnell
went to mansion and the basic deal was
we're going to sign a short-term debt
ceiling extension and that's going to
give us two months to let you guys fight
it out mcconnell's like fine i'll let
manchin fight it out and cinema fight it
out and let those guys fight it out with
biden and sanders maybe they come to an
agreement maybe they don't but whatever
happens next is on them and then if we
hit december and they still haven't come
up with a debt ceiling increase then
it's totally on them because we even
went along with the short term
with the short term extension and they
still couldn't get it together in time
right now it's completely on them just
in time for election season i think that
that mcconnell also has his eye
on the election in virginia because if
we hit november and if youngkin beats
mcauliffe in virginia the billback
better agenda is dead it's doa it's dead
on arrival
there's just not enough moderate
democrats who are willing to sacrifice
their seeds on behalf of an agenda
that's so unpopular dragged terry
mcauliffe to defeat in virginia
once we get next year by the way ain't
nothing getting done
we may be entering
the the end of the legislative phase of
joe biden's presidency already
because nothing's getting done in
election year and then if republicans
win the house which they are very likely
to do in 2022 ain't nothing getting done
for the final two years of joe biden's
presidency
so we already downed at crunch time for
the democrats mcconnell knows that and
every day the democrats are arguing with
each other is a day where democrats
number one aren't getting anything done
and number two
is is a day where republicans aren't in
the headlines and the best thing for
republicans is not to be in the
headlines
the media and biden had successfully
jinned up an out
upset apparently about the debt ceiling
the republicans were like it's just not
worth it
right so joe biden's build that better
agenda is not popular but if he could
some somehow throw mud on the republican
hem then maybe he could distract from
the fact that his agenda isn't popular
this is why for example biden has been
going out there and saying it's wrong
and dangerous not to raise the debt
ceiling
the democrats are willing to step up
and stop this economic catastrophe if
senate republicans will just get out of
the way
but our senate republican friends are
planning to block the vote to raise the
demand the debt limit by using it first
the procedural power called the
filibuster
to say that in plain english it means
you have to have 60 votes and when
there's a filibuster 60 votes a super
supermajority instead of 50 to get
anything done
it's not right
and it's dangerous
for his own part senator senator
mcconnell said quote it's not clear
whether the democratic leaders have
wasted two and a half months because
they simply can't govern or whether
they're intentionally playing russian
roulette with the economy to try and
bully their own members into going back
on their word and wrecking the senate
okay and and so
it's theoretically possible that
democrats now think that they have the
whip hand with regard to mcconnell by
threatening to kill the filibuster over
the debt ceiling but i think that this
was the entire deal i think that the
deal that mcconnell made with mansion
and cinema again this is speculative but
i think it's
given the incentive structures in play
it's probably accurate that basically
mansion and cinema probably went to
mcconnell and they said if it comes down
to the debt ceiling and we are seen as
obstructing the debt ceiling along with
you then it's going to be very hard for
us to push back against the progressives
but give us a little bit more rope and
then whatever happens comes december is
on joe biden
i think that is is quite possible at
this point in time so should mcconnell
be blamed for that
i mean you could say that he caved to a
certain extent because if he had held
the line and maybe democrats would have
blinked first and maybe they would have
used the reconciliation process
or maybe joe biden just would have done
what he's typically done tried to use
executive action by minting a trillion
dollar coin or something like that or
maybe
mansion and cinema were actually
wavering if manchester united were
actually wavering then that meant that
the that mcconnell had lost a lot of
leverage and so he sort of had to do
what he could do here push it off for a
couple months let the democrats fight
one another for the next couple of
months and really not for the next
couple of months really for the next
month right it is currently october 7th
the election in virginia is less than a
month
again away
lot rides on that particular election
so the focus is now back bottom line
focus is now back on the democrats it's
no longer on the republicans hey no more
talk about the debt ceiling
because if we hit december and democrats
still have not been able to get this
together it is entirely on them at this
point and that should be the constant
drum beat from the right
you know we gave you what you wanted you
wanted the extension you got the
extension now if you can't put it
together it is all on you it is all and
by the way if they do put something
together it's gonna be unpopular so it's
kind of a lose-lose for the democrats
okay meanwhile
the
biden administration has yet to see a
political issue that they will not make
into a legal one
it is an astonishing thing what the doj
is doing right now the fbi
so the national school boards
association a little bit earlier this
week sent a letter to joe biden
essentially calling on the fbi to
investigate people who are critical of
critical race theory
it's saying that people who are getting
rowdy
maybe even involving themselves in
low-level criminal activity at school
board meetings are akin to domestic
terrorists
which is pretty insane given the fact
that half the country burned down last
year
according to the national school boards
association america's public schools and
its education leaders are under
immediate threat the national school
boards association respectfully asks for
federal law enforcement and other
assistants to deal with the growing
number of threats of violence and acts
of intimidation occurring across the
nation
local school board members want to hear
from their communities on important
issues and that must be at the forefront
of good school board governance and
promotion of free speech however there
must be safeguards in place to protect
public schools and dedicated education
leaders as they do their
jobs nsba believes immediate assistance
is required to protect students school
board members and educators who are
susceptible to acts of violence
affecting interstate commerce
because of threats to their districts
families and personal safety so they're
looking for a reason why the feds ought
to get involved because of course
criminal activity is criminal activity
at the state and local level if somebody
assaults a school board member that's
not a federal crime that's a local or
state crime you're going to go to jail
for that on the local or state level the
feds have nothing to do with it so why
exactly is the nsba appealing to the
biden administration because they do
wish to chill many of these
conversations
it is their goal to chill conversations
about critical race theory it is their
goal to prevent the feedback loops that
have been really bad for many democrats
on local school boards around the
country
they say quote as these acts of malice
violence and threats against public
school officials have increased the
classification of these heinous actions
could be the equivalence to a form of
domestic terrorism and hate crimes
domestic terrorism and hate crimes truly
the
seriously like this is the direction and
of course because this administration is
in hock to the unions merrick garland
immediately asked the fbi to address the
recent disturbing spike in threats
against educators
so we've now got the fbi involving
itself
saying that the justice department will
hold strategy sessions with law
enforcement in the next 30 days and is
expected to announce measures in
response to the rising criminal conduct
directed towards school personnel in the
nation's public schools
jensake was asked about this at the
white house she was asked whether you
are actually targeting parents not just
the ones who are violating the law but
you're actually using the federal
government to chill speech by targeting
one specific type of real local level
crime
does the administration agree that
parents upset about their kids
curriculums
could be considered domestic terrorists
what the department of justice said in a
letter from the attorney general is that
quote threats against public servants
are not only illegal they run counter to
our nation's core values that is true
these were threats against public
servants threats against
members of the school board regardless
of the reasoning
threats and violence against public
servants is illegal
okay but that does not answer the
question as to why the federal
government is involved in that nobody's
defending threats against public
servants the question is whether the
federal government ought to be involving
itself in local crimes of this nature
and whether that has anything to do with
chilling the entire issue
right juicy said something the school
boards association is asking is for the
administration to consider using the
patriot act to consider investigating
some of these school board protesters so
would the administration be okay with
the fbi using the patriot act to surveil
these parents
and saki said i don't speak on behalf of
the national school board association i
speak on behalf of this government
um
well then why don't you answer the
question on behalf of the government
since you work for the government
okay the fact is being elevated to the
federal level is disturbing
we're being told that critical race
theory isn't being taught in public
schools and then the minute that people
start talking about critical race theory
and then some of the people who are
involved in those discussions do
criminal things it immediately gets
elevated to the federal level
is is there any rationale for that on a
criminal law basis or is it i mean it's
pretty obvious at this point the answer
is no okay in just a second we're going
to get to the politically correct
cancellation of the day
first let us talk about something great
you can do for your family so over at
the couch in our den we have a beautiful
portrait of me and my wife and two of
our three kids we need to get it updated
and when we do that we are going to go
to paintyourlife.com
and get a professional hand-painted
portrait created from any photo at a
truly affordable price or you can
combine photos of people or places you
love into one painting you can choose
from a team of world-class artists and
work with them until every detail is
perfect it's a user-friendly platform
that makes it easy to order a
custom-made hand-painted portrait in
less than five minutes it's fast you can
receive your portrait in as little as
two weeks send any picture you can be
yourself your kids family loved ones
pets people who aren't even there and
they can mash all of those photos up
into a beautiful portrait as well
it makes a fantastic birthday
anniversary or wedding gift it's
meaningful it's personal it can be
cherished forever at paintyourlife.com
there's no risk if you don't love that
final painting your money is refunded
guaranteed
right now is a limited time offer get 20
off at your painting that is correct 20
off and free shipping to get this
special offer text the word ben to 64
000 that's ben to 64 000 text my name
ben to 64 000 paint your life celebrate
the moments that matter most term supply
available at paintyourlife.com terms
again text ben 264 000 to get started
alrighty this coming tuesday october
12th we are making backstage extra super
duper exciting instead of our usual
daily wire studio we will be live
streaming our conversation on stage at
the famous ryman auditorium in nashville
doing what we do best talking sense to
you this will be an event and a live
stream unlike any other we've done we
are thrilled to be able to share it with
all of you plus we'll be making some
extremely exciting and awesome
announcements you're not going to want
to miss those there will be some big
surprises so be sure to tune in join me
kenneth owens jeremy boring michael
knowles matt walsh andrew clavin and our
live audience for a backstage like never
before tuesday's live stream begins at 8
30 pm eastern 7 30 pm central head on
over to
dailywire.com or dailywire youtube to
catch the show
also as the legacy media continues to
spin the news our newest podcast morning
wire continues topping the apple and
spotify charts we're continuing our
commitment to bring you the news without
a hidden agenda it is great it is
convenient it is easy listening it's the
only daily podcast that values your time
and the truth and while we are working
overtime to bring you the news you need
to know we need your help to keep the
facts trending toward number one so
please subscribe start listening right
now to morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts leave a
five-star review if you like what you
hear you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so meanwhile political correctness
continues to run amok in our
institutions so sage steele is a really
really talented broadcaster over at espn
and she does the the noon sports center
she's been doing sportscenter at
at espn for years she happens to be a
biracial woman and she was doing a
podcast with jay cutler
and she made some controversial comments
now in the past she's been pretty openly
somewhat conservative sage has so the
the notion that sage steel was ever
really hiding the ball on her politics
is untrue and she's gotten blowback
pretty publicly from people at espn
about it now remember espn has become
msnbc with footballs esp
espn
spent years broadcasting whatever
idiotic political statements lebron
james wanted to make and then treating
them as though they were some sort of
moses on the mountain moment
anything anything dumb and left that
athletes say is projected into the
stratosphere by espn into anchors spent
four years making overtly political
comments about donald trump for example
to very little blowback unless they said
something so extraordinarily outrageous
that it drew like intense fire pretty
much every day was just dominated by
lies about
policing in the united states or about
systemic racism in the united states
and the espn went woke a long time ago
southern sports illustrated like the
entire sort of institutional sports
media is way to the left of virtually
all media maybe including political
media sage steel is an exception to that
right she's she's tweeted some things
that tend toward the conservative
and while she was on with jay cutler she
made a couple of comments she made one
comment about barack obama she was asked
by jay cutler about barack obama
on a census form saying that he was
black as opposed to biracial which he is
right barack obama is biracial his mom
was white and his dad was black sage
steel is also biracial her dad is black
and her mom is white
and uh and here is uh here's what sage
steele had to say
and and she's like well what happens
when you uh when you fill out your
census i'm like well i don't know when
the last time i filled out my sense this
was but
if they make you choose a race yeah
she's like we're gonna put it i go walt
both she's like well you can't he goes
well what if barack obama chose black
and he's biracial i'm like well
congratulations to the president that's
his thing i think that's fascinating
considering considering
his black dad was nowhere to be found
but his white mom and grandma raised him
but hey you do you i'm gonna do me
okay so how dare she point out the
reality which is that
barack obama
you know characterizes himself as purely
black as opposed to biracial and she
literally says in that clip you can do
what you want right that that's fine
but it's interesting how he
characterizes himself one way as opposed
to another okay fine like that that is a
fairly inoffensive comment when i say
fairly i mean like completely there's
nothing offensive about that right for
her to say that she who has the same
racial status as barack obama chooses to
write mixed race on her forms and barack
obama does not is sort of culturally
interesting that's true that is kind of
a culturally interesting interesting
thing and it demonstrates how our
society tends to box people in to single
race thinking as opposed to the reality
which is that a huge number of americans
in the united states are mixed race and
that continues to grow year on year
there's nothing particularly
controversial about that
and then she had this to say about
vaccine mandate so espn disney they put
down these vaccine mandates like a lot
of other major companies in the united
states sage steel is very critical of
that here's what you had to say
i respect everyone's decision i really
do but to mandate it is um
sick
and it's scary so i get it to an extent
that i think the mandate is what i
really have an issue with and and i
i i don't know i don't know what comes
next
um
but i do know for me personally
i feel
i feel like defeated
okay and uh espn decided that they were
going to suspend her over this so they
issued a statement on tuesday saying
that steel would not return to the
network for a week foregoing her noon
spot on sportscenter and has been
removed as host of the 2021 espnw women
and sports summit taking place october
18th through the 20th
so um that's interesting they said at
espn we embrace different points of view
dialogue and discussion that makes this
place great
that said that said
always that said but
we expect that those points of view be
expressed respectfully in a manner
consistent with our values and in line
with our internal policies um i don't
see anything disrespectful about what
she said she was giving her opinion on
vaccine mandates it seems much more
disrespectful that you are forcing her
to get a vaccine to continue working at
espn and forcing people to continue like
that's what's more disrespectful a
person saying you will be fired unless
you take this vaccine that you have
questions about or the person saying i
think that's sick that you're doing that
which one is more disrespectful
seriously now listen espn's a private
company they can do what they want
with that said
would they have done this had the
situation been reversed and had the
person who was speaking been
hypocritical of president trump or been
hyper sycophantic toward barack obama
which espn was for literally all the
years the barack obama was president i
have serious doubts about that
the reality is that the heads of espn
are all to the left
espn is attempting to cater to a
particular crowd that crowd tends to to
be toward the left demographically
speaking and so sage steele has to pay
the price for that she put out a
statement saying i know my recent
comments created controversy for the
company and i apologize we're in the
midst of an extremely challenging time
that impacts all of us it's more
critical than ever that we communicate
constructively and thoughtfully
so that is um
you know she's i i fail to see what she
says here that is fireable
like truly i i don't understand what she
says here that is fireable or
suspendable that did not stop espn from
suspending her until apparently further
notice
i think there's a pretty good shot that
espn ends up canning her at the end of
this
and i think the reason for that is
because
yeah by the way i think the real reason
for that is espn is trying to cut salary
because they've been losing viewers hand
over fist and i'm sure that stage steel
has been working there for quite a while
makes good money over there and they're
probably just going to find some excuse
to canter because this is what espn does
but again it is just indicative of how
stupid our culture is that if you go on
air and you're a biracial woman you say
something people don't like about barack
obama you might lose your job over it
or if you say that you don't like vax
mandates you might lose your job over
that
meanwhile that's not the only
politically correct attempted
cancellation of the day
so dave chappelle
has a brand new special on netflix and
he sort of alternates his specials he
does ones that are kind of woke and then
highly praised because they're not as
funny but they're woke by the by the
rotten tomatoes crowd and then he does
ones that are actually funny but
politically incorrect so he uh makes
some comments in his new netflix special
about the the phenomenon of turfs
trans-exclusionary radical feminists as
they are called by the trans community
meaning women who say that biological
women exist here is uh dave chappelle
defending jk rowling
i'm team turf
[Applause]
i agree
i agree man
gender is a fact you have to look at it
from a woman's perspective
look at it like this caitlyn jenner whom
i've met wonderful person
caitlyn jenner
was voted
woman of the year her first year as a
woman ain't that something
okay for this sort of stuff glad is now
lambasting dave chappelle and they're
calling for dave chappelle to be removed
from netflix
glad said dave chappelle's brand has
become synonymous with ridiculing trans
people and other marginalized
communities negative reviews and viewers
loudly condemning his latest special is
a message to the industry audiences
don't support platforming anti-lgbtq
diatribes we agree
amazing how the people who are very much
in favor of expanding every quote
unquote right to encompass pretty much
every activity do not include among
those rights speaking what you think
about things then you ought to be
deplatformed so uh amazingly beautiful
stuff here from our censorius left
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon the matt wall show airs
at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check it
out over at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show